Berlin has long been
known as a place where
people can explore their
wildest and deepest
sexual fantasies.
I wanted to find out if
that was really true,
so I've come here.
This building may look innocent,
but inside lives
a dominatrix who's gonna teach me
all about the S&M arts.
And we're in luck, Einfahrt
freihalten happens to be
my safe word.
(audience laughs)
This is Lady Velvet Steel.
Hi.
You are a professional-
Dominatrix.
Yes.
Expert in hand spankings, so,
we should definitely do that.
You're going to spank me?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Like the naughty boy you are.
Uh, okay.
Anything you definitely
don't want to do,
like hard limits?
Um, well,
I'm married.
So, no marks.
So, no marks, yeah.
That's not what I was gonna-
but yeah.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
What is this?
This is like for people
who really like anal play.
So, this is like-
You have a bin.
You know what I love?
You are so organized,
Yes, yes.
You are very anal about (laughs)
anal products.
This is Eternal Dungeon,
what do you expect?
This is incredible.
Yeah, you're all set for tax time.
What does this do?
That's to clean you out,
because like I wanna play
with your ass, not with your shit.
(audience laughs)
I sense that you are a little bit fearful.
My fear is for you.
You may want to retire after you deal,
Well,
with the white anaconda.
I doubt that, but surprise me.
This is where magic happens.
This is fantastic!
Thank you.
These are the, um, the whips?
Oh, it's way too hard to hit somebody,
this is really hard.
So, what do you do with
it if you don't hit people?
Usually I would correct your posture.
Chin up.
Chin up, right.
Shoulders back.
No stomach, I don't like stomach.
So let's take this a step further.
Get your shirt off.
Take the shirt off?
Yes.
Please.
No.
I give the orders, you comply.
Okay, so-
(audience cheers)
Come on, admit, I have
a pretty good, you know,
for a guy in his mid 30s,
I have a pretty good body.
(audience laughs)
Mid 30s, yeah.
Mm, we do role play here,
and fantasy is a big part
of the game.
But yeah, you look good.
You're not nice.
Let's start slow.
Okay, that just feels like a pen.
You're drawing a map of Alaska.
(audience laughs)
Again with the nipple?
All roads lead through
the nipple with you,
don't they?
Yes.
I never feel sexy with the
nipples, I don't know why.
I'm more of a base of the throat guy.
(audience laughs)
Okay, you're not laughing
(audience groans)
at my joke.
Uh, that's painful.
Mm hmm.
I like the pain.
Okay, so you're becoming aroused,
so you owe me 50 Euros,
okay?
I see what you're doing, you're
posting notes on my nipples.
Remember to get milk,
and more fake (bleep).
Oh! My God!
I thought I came here for sexy time.
So far you've pretty much
lectured me on my posture
and removed my nipples.
Quiet.
(audience groans)
So jittery, my God.
(mumbles)
How do you like this?
(audience laughs)
I have concerns.
I'm hoping,
that this shape is not what I think it is.
(audience laughs)
And I'm hoping that this
is, uh, maybe a chess piece,
a rook.
This is a rook.
Oh, no, that's a bishop's hat.
(audience laughing)
I think my parents had one
of these when I was a kid.
Yeah.
And I was like, tryin' to,
and then-
Oh!
Oh, oh oh, look at that.
I was a strong kid.
Did you just break this?
Oh slave.
What?
What did I do?
You are into
a ton of trouble now.
Why am I in trouble?
The harness broke.
That's, that is defective equipment.
Sit down.
I'm guessing this is
an underfunded school.
It is.
(slaps desk)
What happened to the harness?
The harness broke
because it was defective.
If you're talking to me,
you look me in the eye.
Anything else is very impolite.
I don't like impolite students.
Is this understood?
Understood.
Understood who?
Understood, Mistress Velvet Steel.
Excellent, you're a quick learner.
I like that.
Yes.
Smart boy, good.
Yes, very smart.
this student.
What about the harness?
The harness broke
Mm hmm.
because it was defective equipment.
(audience laughs)
(slaps table)
You is the one who made the mistake.
So, it's my fault the harness broke.
I'm unhappy, and you're
getting punished now.
You're going to get up and bend over.
I am very excited about this.
(audience laughs)
Get up and lower your pants.
Uh, well, no, can't do that.
Can't lower the pants.
No lowering the pants.
Not happening,
no.
Hey ah!
(audience laughs)
That's enough.
(slaps)
Oh, oh okay!
Son of a bitch!
(audience laughs)
Get on your knees.
Get on my knees?
Yes now.
That's a hardwood floor.
(shouts in German)
(audience laughs)
Want to be my little doggie?
I'll be your little doggie.
(audience laughs)
Last time I checked
(mumbles)
you're going to woof and bark.
[Conan] Woof.
Good bark, I like that.
Good little doggie.
Are you excited?
[Conan] Woof.
(audience laughs)
Ooh, wag your tail if you’re excited.
[Conan] Woof.
Woof.
Good dog, good dog!
[Conan] Woof.
Excellent.
Sit.
Sit!
[Conan] Woof.
(audience laughs)
Well done.
(camera shutter clicks)
(audience cheers)